black people like everyone else are
flourishing in Florida but don't tell
that to the
NAACP you will not believe this one take
a look at this tweet I mean irony is
dead under the leadership of Governor
Ron DeSantis the State of Florida has
become hostile to Black Americans and in
direct conflict with the democratic
ideals that our Union was founded upon
that's naac president and CEO Derek from
NAACP there I don't even know his last
name Oh Derek Johnson uh Dara Johnson so
they're telling black people don't move
to Florida don't vacation in Florida now
Florida just closed up its biggest year
ever in terms of Tourism like breaking
every freaking record everyone's moving
down here you guys know the numbers 1200
people a day no one cares if you're
black or white frankly I think black
people much like white people like safe
cities they like nice weather they like
clean air they like nice infrastructure
uh things of that nature it's very
strange to think that humans actually
all want the same things but these race
hucksters are everywhere and they are
threatened because The Jig Is up when it
comes to a guy like Rhonda said this he
is standing up to all the BS which is
what we've all wanted this entire
freaking time so here is uh
NAACP CEO Derek Johnson on CNN and he
doesn't care what any reality is about
Florida he wants to scare black people
it's regarding the national group's
notice to certain Travelers we have no
comment however on the economic
diversification front in just the last
few years Florida has moved into the
number one spot in the United States for
black owned businesses and number two
for Hispanic and number two for
women-owned businesses as well when you
hear those numbers uh what they are
saying is look African-Americans and
Hispanics are doing quite well here when
it comes to running their own businesses
and being able to make money here and
being able to live decent lives how do
you how do you address that with this
new band
first of all that's propaganda language
over the last several years it wasn't
because anything he did in policy flawed
by geography is an attractive place
where people would like to go reality is
propaganda language so there are more
black businesses in Florida than
anywhere second for Hispanics second for
women but that does not matter man you
got scary run to say this and we're
gonna scare the hell out of everybody
it's such abject nonsense but they're
throwing in the kitchen sink uh we saw
this right before the show I thought
this was pretty spectacular the chairman
of the NAACP board of directors his name
is Leon Russell guess where he lives
Tampa Florida we've got to help that man
should we start a GoFundMe we will help
to get Leon Russell out of Florida
because it's bad for black people
moronic stupidity never ends
[Music]